أول مرة يأتي شخص إلى منطقة معينة
أظن أنها المرة الأولى التي أرى فيها تلك المنطقة.
المشاعر والأصهار
كما تعلمون، إنها مثل تلك البقرة في كوريا.
الاستهلاك ينخفض ​​فقط في يوم صيفي حار
التسلق من تلك الأرضية الترابية هناك
هناك شيء مثل الرائحة.
يشعر
لقد حصلت عليه للتو على متن الطائرة.
كما يسقط هكذا، الحرارة الحارقة و
الرائحة تأتي على الفور.
حتى الآن، لا أستطيع أن أنسى تلك الرائحة، نعم
لكن الآن أستطيع أن أشم هذا النوع من الرائحة في كل مكان.
لا أستطيع أن أعتبر
لا، لقد التقيت بك من قبل.
أردت أن
السيد سو ليس لي.
[موسيقى]
ساعود
أين منزلي في سيول وغرفتي الآن؟
أنا أعيش على الجانب الروحي.
في سيونجبوك غو
يا إلهي، لقد حان الوقت لتجربتها
اذهب في الاتجاه وقف هناك
لقد ذهبت إلى سامتشيونج دونج، هذا هو حساء الدجاج هناك.
شعرت هناك مرة واحدة
بايكسوك
وكيم كي هوا موجود في بوام دونج، نعم هذا صحيح.
معرض دونغ النضج
سمعت ذلك وذهبت ذهابا وإيابا
لذا
[موسيقى]
[يضحك]
واحد
[موسيقى]
إن لم يكن على الإطلاق
كلما زاد عدد الحانات، كلما زاد هذا
جيي
كوريا
199 1990 في كوريا
vation
الناس خائفون
كان الجو باردًا، نعم، إنه بارد الآن، نعم.
البيسبول
مجموعة
[موسيقى]
لطيف - جيد
للقيام بذلك، يستغرق وقتا طويلا
الرسم لفترة طويلة
لا بأس لمجرد أنك كنت ترسم الأيدي لفترة طويلة.
لا، يمكنك رسمها بسرعة وإبهارها.
يوجد، ولكن كنت أبحث عن شيء من هذا القبيل.
لمس صورة فريدة بالنسبة لي
وحتى في ذلك الوقت، كان هذا ما قاله الناس
وقد تم استقباله بشكل جيد، ولكن حتى الآن،
أنا أستقبله، أولاً، إنه في الخلف هناك.
الصور الذهب
مقدمة
ياخي هذا وقت الكورونا
يزور
منزل سيدني الكبير الكبير لديه
عندما لم تأت اه والآن الأحفاد
مع الشعر
أحفاد
خذ هذا إلى مدريد
زوجة
إن تخطي الوجبة الثانية هو الثاني
كم سنة
2011، وربما في الآونة الأخيرة
أو ربما أريد العودة إلى كوريا مؤخرًا.
هل فكرت في شيء من هذا القبيل؟
في الأول من سبتمبر
ذهبت وأجريت عملية جراحية.
ما دامت الصحة تسمح بذلك، فإن تصريح الفنان هو
الآن أنا بصحة جيدة
إنها عيني، لكني سأجري عملية جراحية لإعتام عدسة العين هذه المرة.
واو، أنت موهوب جدا
لقد تحسنت
دليل السنتين القادمتين أه سنتين
وبعد ذلك يجب أن تكون جميع جوازات السفر
كنت أتساءل عما إذا كان سيعمل
أعتقد أنك قد تعود بالفعل.
يمكن أن يحدث، نعم، ولكن الآن
اه، لقد كان الأمر على هذا النحو لمدة 30 عامًا.
هناك العديد من عمليات البث في وسائل الإعلام والجماهير.
انتبه لمستخدمي YouTube الفرديين مثل هذا
لقد أتيت إلى كوريا بهذه الطريقة وأقوم بذلك.
الأقنعة مثل تلك الموجودة في كوريا.
هل سأتمكن من الحصول عليه؟ما هو؟
أكثر
حياة مهنية
[موسيقى]
قالوا لي إلى أين أذهب إلى مدرسة العام المقبل.
لقد فعلت ذلك، ولكن لم يرتديه أحد.
لا، سأعيش في هذه الحياة بقية حياتي
يتم صقل الجسد بواسطة السيد يوسون.
[موسيقى]
في أبريل
نعم، لقد كنت أرسم منذ الطفولة.
لقد أحببته، كما أحببت الرسم.
الآن، بدلًا من دراسة أي شيء، أرسم.
لقد كان الوقت المناسب للرسم وبشكل عام
أعتقد ذلك، وبعد ذلك
وبطبيعة الحال، نحن الآن نتجه نحو هذا الفن.
أنا أتخذ الاتجاه وأنا
عندما تكبر، سوف تغضب.
أكلته بناء على توصية من صديق.
اقتصاد الشرق الأوسط يركب البناء في الشرق الأوسط
إلى حد كبير، أن لعبة الشرق الأوسط مثل هذا.
إنه جيد، لكني رسمت صورة باللغة العربية.
إذا رسمت شيئًا كهذا به،
ستكون النظرة المستقبلية جيدة مع غروب الشمس
اه، هذه اللوحة الشرق أوسطية من أوائل عام 1978.
لقد بدأت في القيام بذلك لمدة 5 سنوات.
استمر الآن
إفعل ذلك
لقد كنت أفعل ذلك وأنا حقًا ألتقط صورًا كهذه.
بدلاً من النظر إلى صورة أو كتيب
أريد أن آتي وأرى ذلك شخصيا
ما كان هناك وكان له تأثير كبير علي كان
العربي
كان فيلم Los Lagos مؤثرًا جدًا.
أنا أعطيتها لك
في المملكة العربية السعودية في أغسطس 1985، ثم في جيمبو.
بدون توقف إلى الظهران الدولية الكرة
كانت هناك رحلة جوية تابعة للخطوط الجوية الكورية أتت ذات مرة.
المادة التي تصبح صورة
والآن هو 80
جاء في عام 1985 ثم في عام 1987
بعد عودتي إلى المنزل، أقوم الآن بتربية طفلي الأصغر.
كان لدي ابن والآن هو
لقد عدت في فبراير 1990.
هذا صحيح، تعال وخذها هنا
أكثر استقرارا من هذا
إذا كنت ترغب في البقاء، أحضر عائلتك.
يعتقد أنه سيكون جيدا والمناطق المحيطة بها
لأنه كان لديه هذا النوع من السلطة.
عائلتي، عائلتي، في أغسطس 1991
[موسيقى]
انا هنا أخبرني المعلم عن أسلوبه الخاص.
ويبحثون عن أشياء من هذا القبيل
في هذه العملية، أعتقد الآن في كوريا
إذا افترضنا أنك كنت نشطًا طوال الوقت،
نفس الوقت، نفس الصورة، نفس الموضوع
حتى لو رسمتها، قلتها
مثل الآن تعال هنا وافعل هذا
أعتقد أن هناك بعض الاختلافات فيما حدث.
اه بالطبع يوجد كيف نفعل ذلك؟
أنا معجب بالشخص الذي يشتري لوحتي.
كما قلت سابقا يا روحي
هذا يعني أنه عليك الدخول بشغف.
يجب أن أدخل، لكن لا أستطيع التوقف للحظة.
هل هي هناك؟
نيبوس سأريكم واحدًا منهم.
واحد
هناك هذا
نعم، لا يستطيع الجميع أن يحملوا الصورة.
ولا يستطيع الآخرون تقليده
بلمستي وتقنيتي الفريدة،
إذا قمت برسمه والتعامل معه بشكل غير صحيح، فسيحدث هذا
[موسيقى]
لقد فشل
إذن ماذا فعلت الآن؟كوريا؟
شيء كوري وشيء سعودي
لست متأكدا إذا كان الأمر كذلك
على أية حال، أسلوب اللوحة أو شيء من هذا.
وفي النهاية، هذه هي الطريقة التي تسير بها الأمور الآن
لقد حاولت وفعلت شيئًا كهذا.
ثم، في البداية، كان الرسم الكوري.
لقد عملت على اللوحة الكورية المعروفة عادة.
لا، من البداية، من البداية، حسيّ العربي
لقد تخصصت في ذلك في كوريا أيضًا.
الطراز العربي في كوريا أيضًا
مهنيا
[موسيقى]
مثل هذا، مثل هذا
الصور هي من المباني مثل هذا.
مثله
قليلا من هذا أيضا
وبالمثل، الصور من نفس النمط متشابهة.
صور الأنماط والألوان والتراكيب
يملك
من الممل بعض الشيء بالنسبة لي أن أفعل ذلك أيضًا.
روحي فيه هكذا
يقولون، ألا يجب أن أرسم صورة؟
لقد كنت سعيدًا بذلك نوعًا ما
هذا صحيح، منذ لحظة واحدة فقط
كما قلت، لقد وضعته على الهانجي هكذا.
محاولة رسم موضوع عربي مثل هذا
والكثير من العمل الشاق
لذا، أعتقد أن عمر الفنان هو
إنها رتيبة مرارًا وتكرارًا
إذا واصلت القيام بذلك، فقد فات الأوان للقيام بذلك.
ربما سئم هؤلاء العملاء الآن.
لأنها كانت دائمًا تلك الصورة والآن اه
مختلفة عن وظائف مختلفة
في العمل سواء كان مطعماً أو عدواً أو مكاناً للنوم.
اه هناك مجالات كثيرة كوريا
ماذا يمكن أن يفعل الناس هناك؟
أي نوع من أعمال البناء ثم ماذا؟
بعد التصنيع، شيء مثل تقديم الطعام.
ماذا عن مثل هؤلاء الأشخاص في صناعة المطاعم؟
في سن معينة، هو الآن
سواء جاء الأبناء أو جاء الإخوة،
دعونا نواصل الخريف
عندما أنتهي من التنفس، أنا
انتهى الأمر، صحتي تتدهور
عندما لا تتمكن من الإمساك بالفرشاة، استخدمها
لقد انتهى الأمر، ومن ذلك اليوم فصاعدًا، ستكون لوحاتي كذلك
لم تعد موجودة وتختفي.
ثم، لهذا السبب هو أكثر قيمة
هذا هو حبي للوحاتي.
هل هذا صحيح، وهذا هو الأهم و
حقا لم يبق الكثير من الوقت، ولكن
أحتاج إلى رسم صورة مناسبة.
على الجانب الذي يفعل ذلك، نعم، فكر أكثر قليلاً.
يصبح أعمق
هذا هو الفيديو الذي تم تصويره بالأمس
لقد كنت أعمل عليه أثناء التصوير.
انا مبتدئ
لقد مرت 10000 سنة منذ أن بدأت باستخدام كريم الأساس
بعد أن يجف، المسه بشكل أكثر دقة.
بحيث يخلق تأثير ثلاثي الأبعاد
دعنا نقوم به
[موسيقى]
من